démarré en juillet 2014 les travaux de
l'ancien parti du gymnase des pyramides
de voisins-le-bretonneux ont été
l'occasion de rénover le dojo la salle
de danse et le hall d'entrée mais aussi
de remettre le bâtiment aux normes quant
à son accessibilité et à sa consommation
énergétique au niveau de la rénovation
donc il a fallu tenir compte maintenant
donné un handicap et donc par rapport à
ces personnes tout a été bien remis aux
normes
que ce soit donc l'accès à la grande
salle
si à quelques marches à descendre pour y
accéder donc avec une plateforme
handicapées un petit ascenseur et puis
elle est avant tout les vestiaires
surtout ne serait ce que pour penser à
la hauteur des lavabos ou des différents
porte manteaux pour être accessible à
ces personnes environ 250000 personnes
parents adhérents et scolaires circulent
dans ce gymnase une extension il y avait
été installé en 2008 à
voisins-le-bretonneux nous avons plus de
40 associations sportives ce gymnase ne
désemplit pas les salles sont en
permanence plein donc il ya un vrai
besoin parce que voisin est une ville où
les chinois sont sportifs à dernière
étape des travaux dont le coût s'élève à
1,8 million d'euros
des portes coulissantes devraient être
installés à l'entrée du bâtiment d'ici
la fin du mois de septembre